если вы видели в москву увидели
петербург и думаете что вы видели россию
то вы конечно ошибаетесь
чтобы сказать я видел россию
нужно увидеть российскую глубинку вы
помните что такое глубинка
[музыка]
добрый день здравствуйте меня зовут анна
и это канал рашен фром раша для тех кто
изучает русский язык через этот городок
не проходят большие автомобильные трассы
здесь даже нет железнодорожного вокзала
и туристы сюда заезжают не так часто
даже российские туристы я уже не говорю
об иностранцах этот городок
настоящая российская глубинка городок в
глубине
россии можно сказать это не значит что
он находится очень далеко от больших
городов
но он находится далеко от столичной
жизни
называется этот городок устюжна
он на северо-западе россии вологодской
области может быть вы помните в одном из
своих старых видео роликов
года два назад я рассказывала о вологде
а в прошлом году в одном из своих видео
я показывала вам почему точно тоже
находится в вологодской области
а сегодня устюжна расстояние от
петербурга примерно четыреста сорок
четыре километра и городок этот намного
старше чем петербург и не намного моложе
москвы
ему почти 800 лет вот здесь говорят этот
городок
появился на берегу реки малаги им вот
этой вот большой речке там где в эту
реку впадает маленькая
речка ижица сейчас это даже не речка а
такой ручей ручеек
сейчас здесь в этом городке живет около
9000 человек и трудно представить что в
16 веке этот город был одним из
крупнейших то есть самых крупных центров
металлургии и металлообработке в
московском государстве устюжна была
городом кузнецов и оружейников кто такой
кузнец кузнец это мастер который делает
вещи из металла занимается обработкой
металла а оружейник соответственно
делает оружие производят оружие дело в
том что вокруг этого места много болот
болото а в болотах этих было очень много
железной руды и вот представьте себе
из болот добывали железную руду а из
этой железной руды плавили железо
а уже железо обрабатывали и делали
оружие ружья пушки кадра для пушек и
всякие вещи нужные по обычной жизни в
быту замке гвозди и так далее и в
устюжне в 16 веке
проживало примерно 6000 человек и вот на
эти шесть тысяч человек было 77 кузниц
очень много как вы понимаете говорят сам
царь иван грозный приезжал сюда чтобы
проверить как работают местные кузницы и
местные оружейные мастера уже тогда
здесь было 18 церквей и два монастыря
тоже очень много для такого небольшого
городка кстати именно здесь в устюжне
делали решетки московского кремля
а как вы думаете что это такое это можно
сказать тоже вид холодного оружия
называется эта штука чеснок все мы знаем
чеснок который мы едим вот такой чеснок
а этот чеснок
как вы понимаете нужен был совсем для
других целей когда например конница
воины на лошадях на конях наступали
им под ноги бросали вот такой чеснок и
можете представить что происходило потом
уже позднее в россии нашли железную руду
на урале в уральских горах и устюжна
перестала быть центром металлургии здесь
стали делать меньше оружие но кузнецы
продолжали работать и уже сделали больше
замков ключей всяких полезных
в быту повседневной жизни вещей видите
какие замки тогда делали как головоломка
в девятнадцатом веке к пристани на реке
мологе подходили торговые суда торговые
корабли
здесь было много купцов купец это
человек который в царской россии
занимался торговлей покупал продавал и
вот купцы строили дома в центре
устюжны и а знаете кто такой гоголь
гоголь это русский и украинский писатель
classic у него есть очень известная
пьеса которая называется
ревизор эту пьесу в россии знает
наверное каждый школьник потому что в
школьную программу она входит и и
изучают в школе ревизор это человек
работа которого заключается в том чтобы
проверять как работают другие контролер
такой ревизор гоголь рассказал о том что
было на самом деле и история эта
произошла где бы вы думали
именно здесь в устюжне о чем эта пьеса в
маленький городок приехал человек и
местные чиновники
подумали что это ревизор
подумали что этот человек приехал из
столицы чтобы проверить как они работают
то есть местные чиновники приняли его за
ревизора
и хотели они его задобрить то есть
сделать более добрым начали его угощать
приглашать в разные места давать ему
день
деньги предлагать ему деньги и только
потом поняли как они
сглупили то есть как глупо они поступили
эта история произошла здесь в устюжне в
1826 году когда сюда приехал человек
которого звали платон волков и местные
чиновники повели себя так довольно глупо
и потратили уйму денег то есть много
много денег чтобы задобрить этого
платона волкова
эта история является частью истории
устюжны истории городка здесь даже в
музея висит портрет городничего который
в то время руководил пусть южной даже в
местном кафе вы видите одно из блюд
называется жаркое от городничего здесь
даже
гостиница где останавливался платон
волков сохранилась хозяин и я местный
энтузиаст который даже устроил здесь
своего рода подобия
музея видите мы кстати были
единственными постояльцами этого
мини-отеля этой гостинице
постоялец это человек который
остановился в гостинице улица ленина
плавно переходит в улицу карла маркса
переходит она в улицу карла маркса после
пересечения с коммунистическим переулкам
параллельно улице ленен
идет пролетарская улица
а пересекают ее переулок
розы люксембург советский переулок и
переулок луначарского объехать город
можно по улице
энтузиаст и только на окраине города
маленькие улочки с милыми названиями
цветочная кленовая липовая
луговая и крошечный прохладный переулок
вот маленький местный парк с
удивительной скамейкой сделанный
местными кузнецами сейчас еще здесь
работает несколько кузнецов и несколько
кузниц мостик с подковой говорят что
если здесь пройти будет вам счастье
памятник ленину отличается от обычных
памятников ленину которые есть наверное
в каждом российском городе до сих пор
обычно как выглядят памятник ленину
ленин показывает дорогу не знаю в
светлое будущее может быть то есть ленин
стоит с вытянутой вперед рукой
здесь ленин тоже может быть показывает
что-то но может быть робко показывает
неуверенно
[музыка]
по субботам здесь проходит ярмарка
ярмарка это своего рода рынок и ярмарка
бывает не каждый день а по каким-то дням
вот здесь ярмарка по суббота
я была здесь давным-давно детстве мне
было наверное лет двенадцать или
тринадцать
тогда еще в устюжне были деревянные
тротуары сейчас деревянных тротуаров
здесь уже почти нет но честно говоря сам
городок
не очень изменился за несколько
десятилетий и и конечно он не выглядит
очень комфортным местом для жизни
особенно после больших городов
но вот она такая российская глубинка
маленький городок с довольно длинной
историей
но вот и все на сегодня я надеюсь что
вам было интересно подписывайтесь на мой
канал если еще не подписались на мой
аудиоподкаст по субботам и всего вам
самого-самого доброго до свидания и до
новых встреч
увидимся
[музыка]